(electro tempo music)
- All right, welcome to
the Smartphone Awards 2023.
A lot of smartphones come out every year.
And this year is no different.
We got all kinds of shapes and sizes,
and features, and budgets.
Just a ton of phones.
And so like clockwork,
at the end of the year,
you can count on me to pick some favorites
in each of the categories
that I break it down in.
So this is a summary of the best
and some of the worse phones of 2023.
And these are my picks.
I always know I'm gonna get some push back
on some of the categories.
I'm sure I'll hear in the
comments, and I'm fine with that.
But these are my picks,
so I'm sticking with them.
So the way this works is,
I'm gonna break this down
into the usual categories.
Every single category is
going to have one winner.
And then of course,
there can be a runner-up,
and maybe some honorable mentions
if we're feeling generous.
And every single category,
we've actually had custom trophies made
to give to the winners.
And lately the companies that win these
actually do request them,
and sometimes end up displaying
them in their headquarters,
whatever they're into, which is super-cool
for the recognition.
So, we're doing it again.
So without any further ado,
let's get started with our first category.
Best Big Smartphone.
So this is a phone one,
because smartphones have
been growing over the years,
and they've started to
get bigger and bigger.
But at the point we're at now,
it does kind of feel like
they've stopped growing.
Am I the only one who feels this way?
I feel like everyone sort of agreed that
we're not gonna go past
seven inch screen size.
Everything over that is ridiculous.
And so all these big
companies have their giant,
best smartphones pushing right up against
the seven inch screen size.
And trying to fit as much
as possible in that phone.
So, there's a lot of competition in this
particular category.
And my winner for the Best Big Phone,
the best use of that space in 2023...
That's going to the
Samsung Galaxy S23 Ultra.
Once again, the phone that comes out
at the beginning of the
year, kind of a sleeper,
but it holds steady the entire year.
The design is obviously
pretty understated,
which I think is why it goes
under the radar these days.
But it has all the hardware
you could possibly want.
It's got that corner-to-corner 6.8 display
that's super-bright,
quad HD, LTPO, 120 hertz.
It's also got quad cameras on the back.
It's got a 5,000 milliamp power battery.
It's got the second latest
generation snapdragon ship.
Again, it came out in January.
And, it also has room for a stylus inside,
without really sacrificing anything.
Yeah, this thing is full of hardware.
And, it's also gotten
software updates all year,
with a bunch more promised.
It's hard to pick if there's
one standout feature.
It might not be the huge 1440 P screen.
It might not be the 200
megapixel main camera.
But I actually think
it's the massive zoom.
For anyone that cares
about shooting subjects
really far away, this camera system
basically still feels unmatched.
It feels kind of boring.
But it does feel like
that's a pretty clear pick
for me for Best Big Phone of 2023.
But I do have a runner-up.
And this one's not-so-obvious.
Because again, you kind of
get to blur the lines a bit
with these new phones
that have been coming out.
But, I'm giving my
runner-up for Best Big Phone
to the One Plus Open.
It definitely deserves a
mention because when it's open,
becomes almost an eight
inch square display.
This phone, even this
new folding form factor
has all the hardware
you could possibly want.
And all the software features to match.
And I really enjoyed using
this phone this year,
despite how gigantic it is.
But I do also wanna
give honorable mentions
for Best Big Phone to Asus ROG Phone 7.
And Oppo Find S6 Pro.
Not these phones are lacking anything.
Again, the boring one won.
But maybe if this one
had wireless charging,
or if this one had more zoom,
it could of been in contention.
But these are two also
excellent giant phones
that came out this year.
So then, next up category,
Best Compact Smartphone.
Best Small Phone.
This one, I swear the pickings get slimmer
every single year.
Because not only are smartphones
getting bigger and bigger,
but also even the smallest
phones are getting further
and further from small.
Like the smallest phones
from the biggest companies
are still, do you wanna
call a pixel 7A small?
That's a 6.1 inch screen.
Or maybe Galaxy S23, the baseline one,
that's also a 6.1 inch screen.
It's tough to find a truly small phone
that brings all the
flagship features down.
But there's one that really did it.
And so, it definitely deserves this award.
The Best Small Phone, you
saw this coming already.
It's the Asus Zenfone 10.
This is the flagship that
packs everything you need
and more, in an actually
one handable phone,
with a 5.9 inch display.
So, it deserves to be the winner.
And I'm so glad that this phone exists.
When I reviewed the Zenfone 9 last year,
I said it was pretty close to perfect.
It was just missing a couple of things.
It had a couple of small nitpicks.
When I reviewed the Zenfone 10 this year,
they fixed those nitpicks,
they added wireless charging.
They made the back of
the phone more durable,
some software tweaks.
It's literally nearly perfect.
If you are thinking about
buying a small phone,
honestly it feels like this may be
one of the last good
ones you ever get to buy.
If you're in the age of
wanting a mini phone,
speak now, or forever hold your cash.
'Cause they're going away.
The only other phone that I
think could technically qualify
for this, would be some
of the folding phones.
Or flipping phones, I should say.
Chief among them being Samsung's Z Flip 5.
Now when you open up the phone,
you're still getting a pretty big screen.
It's as 6.7 inch screen,
when you actually use a Z Flip 5.
But, as many of you have pointed out,
you can fold it down and
stow it in a much smaller
form factor than the others.
So even though it's not
the most one handable thing
in the world,
it's smaller.
So, shout out to the Z
Flip 5, Honorable Mention.
So next category the Best
Camera in a smartphone in 2023.
And this one I have a soft spot for,
just 'cause I like cameras,
and you guys already knew that.
But there has been a lot
of really interesting stuff
pushing the boundaries
for smartphone cameras.
In the past year, especially.
A lot of it optically
with really cool hardware.
A lot of it with software,
with processing, with
AI, with all the stuff...
I mean, I might end up
making an entire video
on just how crazy it's gotten,
because there's been some
really interesting stuff lately.
But, my pick for best camera for 2023,
ruffles feathers every
time for some reason,
but I really believe in this one.
You already know, it's iPhone 15 Pro.
This is my camera king.
And I have absolutely no regrets about it.
Now, it's a simple fact that
many people love to point out
is yes, there are some smartphones,
even ones on this table that
can produce better photos
than the iPhone in certain situations.
Especially zoom.
But when it comes to just
the totality of performance
across the biggest variety of situations,
and ease of use for photos and videos,
the iPhone is still king.
Especially with a video.
I feel like it's still
not particularly close.
See iPhone takes the best,
most consistent usable videos
in the biggest variety of
situations of any smartphone
by a long way.
They also added log recording
to the Pro iPhones this year.
They can also record
directly to an external SSD.
There was an Apple
keynote earlier this year
that turned out to be shot
completely on the iPhone,
and it looked incredible.
But some of you may already remember,
and I've pointed this out,
that's not the first time
that's happened already.
Samsung years ago did a
keynote that was live,
that was actually already shot.
And they announced it on the phone.
But you could tell,
like it wasn't nearly as good.
You really could tell.
So this thing has been
producing incredible results.
Basically if you told me I could only have
one smartphone camera
for the next five years,
I think I would pretty
quickly just go "All right.
"Let's just send it
with the iPhone 15 Pro."
I do also wanna give an
honorable mention, though.
To the Galaxy S23 Ultra.
This thing, especially
because of how well it does
with the zoom, has been
an awesome stills camera
for a long time.
Really good.
It also, I did a whole
video on it, reviewing it.
The 200 megapixel thing,
didn't turn out to be
a big of a difference
versus the 100 megapixels
as you might of though.
But in general, really good.
And then, a shout out to the winners
of our scientific blind
smartphone camera test
that we ran online again this year.
We collected data from 20
smartphones that came out in 2023
and the overall most popular winner
for the standard photo was the Pixel 7A.
Then the winner for low light
photos was the iPhone 15 Pro.
And the winner for portrait
photos was the Pixel 8 Pro.
So next category, next
winner is Best Value.
Sort of shifted over the years.
It used to be Best Budget Phone.
But I sort of expanded it,
Best Value Option here.
And this is actually I
think the hardest one
for me to pick.
Believe it or not, which
I think is a good thing,
and a bad thing.
It's a good thing,
because it means there's some competition
in the high value options.
But it's also not that good of a thing,
just because a lot of phones
have gotten price hikes this year.
There have been base prices going up.
Things that used to win budget awards
are more expensive now.
So I gotta make that
decision on what qualifies
as best value.
Like we all think a $1,000 phone
should not win Best Value, right?
Even if it's a great phone.
But, how high is too high?
But after much deliberation,
I eventually landed on what
feels like a sweet spot.
A phone with basically
no stand out features,
but also basically nothing wrong with it.
The phone can be found
consistently for well under $400.
It's the Samsung Galaxy A54.
It's everything you need,
and nothing you don't.
Like you could go more
premium and get more features,
and feel like you're
enjoying the phone more.
But you could also go a little cheaper,
and start to notice a little
bit more corner-cutting.
But this does a really good
job of striking the balance
right in the middle.
You know how when someone asks
you like how your day's been
and you just kind go, "Oh, it was fine."
"Nothing really happened,
"it was all right, nothing notable."
That's this phone. Cameras are fine.
Battery, it's fine.
The screen, it's fine.
The design is fine.
Everything is fine.
So, for $400 bucks, you'll be just fine.
I also wanna give an
honorable mention, though.
Because there is a phone
that dipped way down below
what I thought a really
good phone could be.
And that is the Moto G Play.
I reviewed this phone
as it came out at $169.
And to be honest, I was
very impressed with it.
And kind of evaluating the whole idea
of how a phone could be
decent at this price.
90 hertz and everything.
But also give a shout out to the Pixel 7A.
As you probably remember,
the price went up this year,
all the way up to 500 bucks.
But it did gain some stuff.
It has a 90 hertz display now.
It has better specs, and it still does
all the stuff that you
expect from a Pixel.
So, it deserves a shout
out for being a good phone
at that price.
So then, next up.
Best Battery.
Best Battery overall in a smartphone.
This doesn't necessarily go to the one
that just has the
highest battery capacity.
I'm more giving Best Overall
Battery Experience award.
Ideally, you also have some
decently fast-charging,
or wireless charging.
Or, it's just convenient
that it lasts for so long.
It might not actually be the biggest sell.
I don't know that anyone's
actually buying a phone
just because it has the
absolute best battery life.
But if you do live that life,
that no worries away from a charger life,
you'll probably care about
the winners of this category.
So my winner, who's getting a trophy
for best battery this year is
iPhone 15 Plus, specifically.
This thing just goes and goes, and goes.
The bigger battery, in general,
has a lot to do with it.
The 60 hertz display, also
But, if you want a risk-free no-brainer
great battery life, that's definitely
gonna get it done for you.
I'm also gonna give a shout
out to the ROG phone 7.
It doesn't have wireless charging,
but it does have pretty fast charging.
And it has the biggest battery capacity
of any phone I've used this year.
6,000 milliamp powers.
And if you drop it down to 60 hertz,
it will also just go, and go, and go.
And also, another Asus phone,
which is the Zenfone 10.
This one kind of feels like wizard-like.
I don't know how, because
it's not the biggest battery.
It is pretty aggressive at
killing background apps,
and it's probably missing
some bands in the U.S.
So, that might have
something to do with it.
But this phone, this small
5.9 inch display phone,
it's killer battery life.
It can be a two day phone.
And you can drop it down
to 60 hertz, as well.
So, whatever Asus is doing
over there, keep it up.
Because battery life is great.
I recently talked about
this in my hot takes video
about how phones are getting
more and more powerful.
But generally the average
battery life hasn't
really changed that much.
It's just been all day is good.
So it's good to see some
phone actually pushing
that envelope, and they
deserve to get rewarded for it.
So then, Best Design.
This one is so tough every time.
Best Design.
Because first of all,
design is subjective.
Like something I find pretty,
you might find ugly. Fine.
But also just in general, it
feels like every phone has
some flaw, some reason why,
and I can't give it to that one.
Like think about it,
if you're in my shoes,
you gotta give a design award, right?
First of all, a lot of
phones look pretty similar
to the way they did the
previous year, right?
So I can't give it to one
that looks exactly the same as last year.
But also, I can't give it to one that has
some fatal flow, if it's missing
a camera it should of had,
or if it's missing, it has a crazy bezel.
I can't give it to the one
with the biggest notch,
or dynamic island, can I?
I can't give it to the one
that's made of plastic,
or the one that has a
curved display on the edges.
Like what is an actually flawless,
maybe it's the most boring design.
But, you don't wanna give the design award
to the most boring design.
This is a hard one.
And then it hit me.
There was a phone this year
that basically made headlines
just for its design.
In a good way, and I agreed with them.
And it absolutely deserves a
trophy for design this year.
It's the Honor Magic V2.
This thing right here.
This phone legitimately
shifted the way I think
about phone hardware.
It was like a gear shift in
the world of foldable phones.
A think a lot of us didn't even realize
that you could make a phone like this.
That has, first of all, it's
under 10 millimeters thick,
when it's closed.
Which is the same thickness
as plenty of regular phones.
It has a full-sized screen on the outside.
It has a corner-to-corner
foldable display on the inside.
It somehow also fits a 5,000
million power total battery.
Which I think is the biggest
I've seen in any foldable.
Toss in 60 plus watt charging,
a triple camera setup,
a terabyte of internal storage.
I think a lot of us didn't
realize this was possible.
So even though the rest of the phone
might be a little questionable,
maybe some weird software
that I wouldn't wanna use,
the one thing that nobody
could question is the design.
Everyone I've shown it to
universally is impressed
in some way by it.
But that actually brings us
to our first new category ad
in a long time in the Smartphone Awards,
and that is Best Foldable Phone.
So this is the first time
genuinely separating out,
and considering all of the folding phones
that came out during the year.
And the reason it's getting
its own category this year
is because there's
genuinely a large variety
of shapes and sizes and
versions of foldable phones,
and flippable phones
that we can choose from.
So I think in general,
I made a video talking about this already.
But folding phones are
quite on the doorstep yet.
Like, they're close,
but they're still mostly
thicker and more expensive
than normal phones.
But, I do wanna reward the ones
that are pushing the
boundaries in some way
towards that revolution.
So, winner for best
foldable phone in 2023,
yeah, that's the OnePlus Open.
Man, this phone is good.
When I was thinking about
what I would personally
daily drive from the folding phones bunch,
this is the one that bubbled to the top.
This is folding phone I
would be most likely to use.
When it's closed, it feels
the most like a normal phone.
Mostly because the aspect
ratio on the size of the screen
is normal phone-ish, flat sides.
But then you open it up,
and it's a nearly eight
inch, almost perfectly square
folding screen with a very minimal crease.
Awesome specs, really good software,
and a lot of fun features to back it up.
I think my favorite part is just the way
you can move around multiple windows
and keep them full-size.
And have them overlap sort
of the edge of the screen.
It's a fun and unique,
like actually new way
of multi-tasking on a phone.
And it actually works.
This was the best phone
with a folding screen
that was released during 2023.
No doubt about that.
It's also basically
the exact same hardware
as the Oppo Find End Three Fold.
So, shout out to that one, as well.
But I also wanna give an
honorable mention here.
I'm gonna actually say it's the runner-up
in this category of best foldable.
To the Pixel Fold.
And that's just because
this one specifically
is my favorite foldable to use closed.
Because the outside screen is so good.
The outside screen is nice and compact.
It's the most reachable,
it's the smallest, also.
But it's wide, it's big, it's
super useful to use closed.
And for whatever reason,
I love that about it.
I don't know if that's a
good thing or a bad thing,
that I opened it way less.
But it's the best to use closed.
And, I'm gonna give an
honorable mention as well
to Samsung's Z Flip 5.
I mentioned it earlier in this video.
But, a couple of things about this.
One is, it feels like
it's leading the pack
for the flipping phones.
I think it's better than the Razer,
I think it's better than some
of the other flipping ones.
But also as far as build quality,
and just quality control,
Samsung in general, is
at the top of the heap.
Basically every other folding phone
has had some level of
quality control issues
at some point and some rate.
And Samsung ironically, the ones that had
the biggest issues at the beginning,
have ironed it out the most over time.
So that's their reward
for jumping in early.
Also, I have to give
that honorable mention
to the Honor Magic E2,
just purely for the design.
I still can't believe
they made this phone.
Super-impressive.
So, next award, Most Improved.
The Most Improved Award.
Hmm.
It's interesting because again,
lots of phones play it safe.
Lots of phones are just a
slight evolution from last year.
They're a slight spec bump.
And I can't get mad at that if
they're already a good phone.
Like Zenfone, for example.
I'm happy they kept a
lot of things the same.
But then, that makes
the Most Improved Award
a little more of a quirky pick.
Maybe not the most
obvious pick in the world.
But I'm gonna go with the Nothing Phone 2.
Most Improved Phone 2023.
So this is part hardware story,
and part a software story.
So obviously, they didn't
change the hardware
a ton from the first Nothing Phone.
Because they're literally brand new,
so they're just getting
their identity set.
So yeah, there's a newer,
higher resolution LED pattern
on the back.
There is a slightly curved glass now
to feel a little better in the hand.
But generally, it still
looks like a nothing phone.
But they also did a lot with the software,
specifically moving to
Nothing OS 2.0 and then 2.5.
Which now on Android 14.
Which gets a lot of new
stuff with this phone.
There's a focus on
efficiency and smoothness,
and then adding all these features.
And there's also been fantastic.
So you combine that with the new specs,
the slightly bumped design,
and then a bunch of the new
features that unfortunately
the Phone 1.0 isn't getting,
like the better glif controls,
and clone app feature,
and monochrome theme and stuff.
It just adds up to a
pretty big improvement.
To the point where in this world
with most people just being
able to buy last year's phone
and be totally fine.
With this phone, I would actually say,
don't buy last year's phone.
You should just get the
Phone 2, over the Phone 1.
Plus you can send blue bubbles to,
oh, wait, sorry never
mind, you can't do that.
But still, Phone 2, much improved.
It's probably gonna steady out after this.
And this was nice to put them on the map.
But now, they'll have to stabilize
and become a real company.
And you know what? Honorable Mention.
Just because I don't know
if anyone else can say
they technically made this
big of a change in their phone
as much as switching the
iPhone 15 to USB type C.
So, Honorable Mention to the iPhone.
All right, next up.
Bust of the Year.
The award you don't
really wanna have to give,
but one of these phones on this desk
is gonna win Worse New Phone of 2023.
Look, I do have to preface
this basically every time
by saying, it is actually
genuinely hard now
to get a bad phone.
Like most phones, no matter
what price point you're at
are either gonna be
really good for the money,
or okay for the money.
It's hard to get a bad phone.
But there was one bad phone this year.
And so, it's gonna win a trophy for it.
And that would be Solama Saga Cryto Phone.
Bust of the year.
There is actually no price
that I would recommend
anyone buys this phone.
Buying this phone is
like buying a timeshare.
It might seem like a good
idea for two seconds.
But the second you actually do it,
you realize how horrible
of an idea it was.
And, this is just a bad phone.
The one redeeming quality is actually
it does have this nice build quality.
It's got ceramic, and it's
nice and weighty and heavy.
But yeah, that was wasted on this phone.
You could tell because
of the story behind it.
That it wasn't going to go well.
I'll leave a link below to the full video
I did about it, if you have any itch
to just hear about something horrible.
But that's a pretty clear
one for bust of the year.
I'm also gonna give an honorable mention
to all of the concept phones
that were announced this year
and never came out.
And never will.
You know who you are.
So that brings us to the
biggest trophy of the night,
well, it's the same size
as the other trophies,
but it's the most important,
it's the best one.
It's the one you wanna win, the MVP.
The Most Valuable Phone.
Well, not actually valuable value-wise,
but it's really just my
favorite phone of the year.
At the end of the day,
it's come down to like,
there are really good phones.
They are the ones that
have the biggest impact
on the industry.
They're the ones that are the
most fun, the most unique,
the most innovative,
the ones that have the best features.
And this one sort of
just combines all of that
into one trophy of
recognition for the MVP,
the Phone of the Year for 2023.
So, what's it gonna be?
I mean, there's been some
really interesting stories.
There's been some disruptive phones.
There's some great phones
that I've enjoyed using.
My winner for MVP, for
Phone of the Year 2023,
is going to the Pixel 8.
Well-deserved, big shout
out to the Pixel 8.
It has stepped it up over last year.
So there's a bunch of
things about this phone
that are genuinely
different from last year.
But the headlining one, the
one that matters the most
is it's a $100 more
expensive than the Pixel 7,
so it's really gotta
deliver and be a great phone
to be worthy of that.
And it does.
This phone has a great camera.
Not miles ahead of the
rest like previous years,
but still and incredible
stills photo camera.
It has a dramatically better display.
It's stepped up to a 120 hertz.
It's got this flagship class, 2000 knits.
Super-bright.
It also has the same tensored
G3 chip as the Pro Phone,
which is several hundred dollars more,
and also a flagship.
And then, just a ridiculous
amount of software features.
Again, matching the more
expensive Pro Phone,
which makes it harder and
harder to justify the Pro Phone,
which I use daily and love.
But still, for the
hundreds of dollars less,
this is the way you should probably go.
And, it's promising now seven
years of software updates.
Seven years of software updates,
which is pretty incredible for a phone.
So just among all the things
that came out this year,
as far as a well-rounded
package for impact,
for price, for stepping it up,
and being a really good phone, Pixel 8.
Now, I do have a runner up.
I really again, super-love
this phone this year.
And it's not gonna be a
popular phone, either.
But I love it anyway.
It's the Asus Zenphone 10.
Some of you already know,
because of what it did last year,
how good these phones are.
And it does it again in this
weird physics-defying package
of basically being nearly perfect.
Small, compact, reachable,
surprisingly-good cameras.
Excellent performance,
shockingly good battery life.
Just, I don't have a
lot of bad things to say
about this phone.
Zenphone 10, it's really good.
You should watch the full review.
And, I'm also gonna give
an honorable mention
to iPhone 15 Pro.
Specifically for basically now feeling
like we've reached peak iPhone.
I know you could of said this about
a lot of previous iPhones.
But, now that it is USB type C,
and now that the notch
has been gone for a bit,
and is a dynamic island.
This just feels like a finished phone.
There's not a whole lot of other things
that I'm expecting to land
with a bang on the iPhone.
Maybe a fingerprint
reader, or fast-charging.
Maybe that's about it.
But, this is the best
iPhone ever, clearly.
And I feel like it's
finally hit that stride of
"All right, you've done it."
Two other quick mentions.
I do have to give a shout out,
an honorable mention to
the ultra-boring S23 Ultra.
Just because this is that phone that is,
it doesn't have any flaws,
it's just a rock-solid phone all around.
And it consistently gets buried
when you think about the December videos.
The phone that came out 12
months ago, but I have to.
This is a really good phone.
And, I wanna give a shout
out to the One Plus Open
for being the foldable phone that I think
I could actually recommend to real people.
Not that most people are
gonna spend 1800 bucks
on a foldable phone, anyway.
But if you're going to for one of them,
this is the phone that I would daily,
if you had to tell me to
pick a folding phone today.
So shout out to the One Plus Open.
And, that's it.
That's my Smartphone Awards for 2023.
So let me know how all of you are feeling.
I know there's gonna
be comments down below,
and I can't wait to hang
out and see which ones
you would of picked for your awards.
Maybe other people will
make their own awards, too.
But, I'm pretty happy with my list.
So, until the next one,
catch you guys later.
Peace.
(lively music)